well these shadow climate change
secretary Ed middleband is with me now
good morning Edmond thanks for being
with us this morning so Simon Clark said
that they fixed the roof when the Sun
was shining and now there's a storm
coming the sun is definitely not shining
and their plan is going to work well let
me start with the freeze because we
called for an energy price freeze in
August and if the government does a
proper freeze and we've got to look at
the small print of this then we will
welcome it because I think it is very
important for families and businesses
that are facing appalling circumstances
but there is a question which you were
asking Simon Clark about who pays now of
course there's a role for responsible
government borrowing in the time of an
emergency but we know from the treasury
that there's 170 billion pounds of
excess profits that the energy companies
are making as a result of this crisis
and lives trust through dogma and
ideology is choosing not to use that
money to help pay for this for this plan
and I think that's wrong when you say we
know he wouldn't confirm that figure so
where are you guys going did he deny
that figure he said he couldn't confirm
all right well that sounds like it's
true that's normally what government
ministers say when something's true look
we know there's huge profits out there
and we can go we I can go through it
with you in oil and gas we know there
are huge profits and we know that even
though Rishi sunak put a windfall tax
forward he built in a 5 billion pound
tax loophole we know the electricity
generators are making huge profits too
and they've been independent reports
from a conservative think tank saying
that we could raise as much as 10
billion pounds from the Tony Blair
Institute as something like 10 to 20
billion pounds so we know there's tens
of billions of pounds out there Kamali
which could be used to help pay this
bill
why not I mean your plan is 28 billion
pounds you say it's fully funded but
it's only for six months and every time
I ask someone from the labor party what
you do for the next six months say oh
we're going to wait and see I mean
you've been outflanked here entirely
this is going to run if it's as reported
18 months well I don't accept that look
we set out the principle of an energy
price freeze in August I was on this
program and I was being asked is this
Fez it's the right thing to do should we
be helping everyone Liz trust didn't
agree with the plan she said it was a
sticking plaster if the government's
accepted the principle of the freeze
then that is a good thing for my from
our point of view if it's two years
that's a good thing but then there's
this question about how it's funded I
mean and it also sets up a time bomb in
two years time doesn't it because I mean
if it's just there for two years who
thinks the war's gonna be over by then
well and this is the point and this
takes us to the issue of fracking let me
just be clear with your viewers about
this the only way out of this crisis in
the long term is to get off fossil fuels
you see fracking there's an issue about
where the fracking safe because the
government stopped fracking because they
said because of earthquakes and they
said it was dangerous but even leaving
that to one side if they can satisfy
people on that
the price of fracked gas will be exactly
the same as the price of imported gas
because gas is sold in the international
market that is nine times the current
price of Renewables onshore wind solar
there's only one way out of being in the
grip of the geopolitics of Putin and
others and that is a clean energy Sprint
and I'm afraid the government seems to
be setting its face against that if it's
our own gas that's brought up from the
earth in Blackburn or wherever else we
have these freaking places yeah that was
going on to wholesale Market you can't
keep that and having our own prices
exactly you see that it's sold on the
integrated market and believe it or not
quasi quateng who was the business
secretary is now the chancellor was
saying precisely this in February of
this year when he was against fracking
he was saying look it's going to make no
difference to prices it'll take years to
come on stream now the government's
YouTube I think it's another case of
ideology trumping common sense and what
actually is needed for the country but
it's not just about prices because of
course it goes on the wholesome Market
it's about having that security it's
about not being in hooked to to Vladimir
Putin although we get very small amount
of gas from Putin which I know you're
going to tell me it's about not having
to bring it in from other places
definitely and let me tell you how we
get that security quicker cheaper much
more sensible onshore wind which the
government is currently blocking solar
Farms so solar panels which the gut
which Liz trust says she's against
nuclear offshore wind and crucially
Energy Efficiency which the government
refuses to do we could be cutting the
amount of gas that we're using if we're
insulating the 19 million coal drafting
homes not entirely Fair Mr Clark said he
welcomes those those wind farms and Liz
trust says she doesn't want to see solar
panels on Farmland that could be used
for other things
welcomes wind farms then maybe you can
get him back on the program and you can
tell us that he'll lift the band that
there currently is in England on on
onshore there has been the policy that's
coming well I'd be very surprised if
there is because the truth is that the
the small section of the conservative
party that seems to have voted for Liz
trust is absolutely oppose them and even
Boris Johnson didn't didn't bring in
that didn't get rid of the band I mean
what we're really seeing here is like a
real real divide isn't it between the
two ideologies that the two leading
parties have I mean you do you welcome
that that we've seen two Clear Choices
for the electorate well I don't welcome
what Liz truss is doing because I don't
think she's doing the right thing you
know I think what you're seeing is the
labor party that will make Fair choices
on behalf of the British people and will
make sensible choices when it comes to
our long-term Energy System and I'm
afraid Liz truss that is seems to have
been persuaded by dogma and ideology
which won't serve the country well
but you welcome the idea of borrowing in
an emergency and that's what she
essentially wants to do well I think
it's sensible as we did during covid
when there is this kind of Emergency on
I think it's sensible to have
responsible government borrowing but I
don't think that's the first Port of
Call the first protocol as we've
discussed is these enormous profits that
these companies are making and the
government says that you can't tax your
way to growth and also if you increase
that windfall taxes there's a let's
recognize well there is all the whimple
tax in place which is going to raise
some 15 billion pounds I think that's
what they said with the carve out as you
mentioned
um but if you increase that rental tax
you're going to discourage investment
which we need to make sure that we can't
because let me put it this way the chief
executive of BP was asked before the
windfall tax came in would a win full
tax which which of your Investments
would a windfall tax stop happening he
said none of them if the chief executive
of BP is saying a windfall tax wouldn't
impact on investment you know what what
why is the government saying he's wrong
I might often put that to conservative
MPS and they tell me that that's just
one chief executive it just happens to
be one of the largest oil oil and gas
companies in the world I mean how
concerned are you the way that the
markets are reacting to the proposed
plan that we're seeing here the pallet
is lowest level since 1985. well look I
think responsibility and fiscal
responsibility is really important and I
think Liz trust would be in a better
position and a quasi-quarter in the
chance will be in a better position if
they were saying well look we started by
looking at how we can get this through
taxation and then yes government
borrowing is necessary they haven't done
that you know obviously I want the
economy to succeed I want them to make
responsible choices I mean it's a change
of roles isn't it that you're describing
the conservative party is fiscally
irresponsible well well yeah I think
there does need to be fiscal soundness
in our decision making and you know we
can come on to Liz truss's plan to cut
Corporation tags that's another 17
billion pounds which we don't know where
it's going to come from and frankly
Kamali if the if the issue is the 17
billion pounds to give away it will be
much much better to use that money to
for example rescue the National Health
Service from the position it finds
itself in let's talk a little bit more
about clean energy Jacob resmorg is now
in business base as it's now called um I
welcome him to his role I hope you might
say something like that and I mean how
um in the spirit of cooperation and how
confident are you that clean energy is
going to be safe with him in that
department I'm not at all confident
about it you know I am really worried I
know Jacob Reese monk personally we get
on personally but I'm worried about his
views you know he has questioned climate
science
he has made all kinds of comments over
the last decade about how can we know
about climate science he's questioned
the very basis of the decisions we make
on the climate crisis now the reason
that matters is not just because of the
climate crisis it's because if we are
going to get to the cheaper bills we all
want to see we've got to go Health
leather for all of all of the clean
energy we have nuclear you know some
people find that controversial but
nuclear is part of it onshore wind
offshore wind at solar all of those
things and Energy Efficiency and I worry
that he said his face against a number
of those things we'll have to see how he
behaves in that department um Ed Miller
Band Shadow secretary for climate change
internet there appreciate your time
thank you so much